[Music]
we wanted to talk about which games have
done post release content right and
compare that to a games such as
battlefront 2 that seemed to be
struggling to grasp that and games with
loot crate so let's start with loot
crate's because that's kind of where
what seems to have sparked all this I
don't want to go back as far as like
Mass Effect 3 with loot crate's because
that's the first one I can remember
which was also EA I want to go back to
overwatch which seems to be the one that
really sparked the fire recently really
dude it right yeah yeah you can start
you could argue yeah you can argue that
it's just their fault but I mean they're
all aesthetic where's battlefront is
actual abilities and whatnot obviously
if you have played overwatch you can get
loot crate's which just end up giving
you new character skins sprays victory
poses emotes what am I missing or just
more gold to spend on ones that you
definitely want to get so that's the one
silver lining here of several I guess
it's not just the one but you can
actually buy specific skins if you have
enough gold hmm this you know makes me
always and this is not really feeding
into the argument with any sort of
definitive stance but when you think
about like old-school RPGs or any games
that would reward you for going into
battle against some you know enemies and
stuff you would pray to get that rare
item dropped from them they were
essentially walking loot crate's but
there was like gameplay involved in it
so it didn't feel like this layer like
once removed just sort of puts you in a
different mindset and system and I think
that is probably the the biggest issue
here where I think people can look at
overwatch and say even though it's just
cosmetic yeah like it's still this
randomized thing that you have to put in
a lot of time and effort for and pray
that you get what you want and that's
why so many people like Belgium and
Hawaii and everyone are saying this
should be considered gambling and should
how many times but it's not a people so
so many people in places such as Belgium
yeah
running governments such as those in
governments covered gubernatorial roles
in Belgium and Hawaii are saying it
should be considered gambling a lot of
people are already saying CD Projekt RED
does it really well with witcher 3
blood and wine specifically the dlc
actually gave you Toussaint
like this whole new reason to explore
much like Point Lookout and fallout 3 if
you're talking about new Vegas like the
Lonely Hearts stuff they actually added
these new areas and that was all paid
DLC but you pretty much know what you
were getting witcher 3 like again they
give you another like 50 hours in blood
and wine if you really want to spend all
the time digging into that and people
seem to think CD Projekt in general i
know which or two had some dlc as well
like I said Rainbow six siege does it
really well although they introduced the
loot crate's this year with for
aesthetic options which I'm kind of
bummed about because it can take so
renown is the you can I don't know if
it's snowing out on the screen right
here no renown is your actual currency
in the game and there are Rainbow six
credits which you could that's real
world money those might as well be
crystals and those can be used to buy
certain uniforms or headgear or weapon
skins for different operators you might
see in the b-roll here some of these
weapons have crazy skins they I don't
really it's like one of the small
problems I have with the game I guess
it's kind of big and I mean the loot
crate's work much like we've been having
problems with you they're not randomized
is the only thing I would say so it's
not loot crate's in the sense that you
know they're you don't know what you're
getting you do know what you're getting
but it still does take a while to grind
if you want to get all the renown
possible because when a new operator a
new operator group comes out you can
either if you don't have a season pass
which is like thirty dollars a year and
you get renown bonuses or there's a few
you yeah you get renown bonuses or and
you'll have access to the operators like
a week early or you'll have actually you
know you'll be able to play them before
everybody else it it doesn't actually
affect the game too much but again if
you want to actually get unlock these
operators they're not available from the
get-go they'll be like 25,000 renoun and
that could take like ten hours to get so
I don't know I'm worried about this game
going forward if you don't have a season
pass I mean I guess you could consider
that season pass like you pay $30 for
blood and wine The Witcher expansion
this season pass could be considered
that if you playing this game a lot and
you know like I don't know we're doing
the point where like oh well it's all
aesthetic so it's not affecting the game
but like at this point is still this
isn't randomized loot crate's but it
still does take a while and it seems
like they're encouraging you to pay
money for it yeah I mean I don't I don't
know I I think for a game like a game
that is that you mostly play
competitively like an overwatch or Remo
six I like for me with overwatch though
the whole fun of the loot crate's is I
have these couple characters that I
really like there are my mains and I'm
striving to get cool skins for them
because I like playing them and that I
don't know I don't have a problem with
that because personally I'm not the kind
of person who would spend money on that
sort of like there's nothing that like
gives me an advantage just just like
something to work towards and I think
that's a tricky balance to strike I
don't really know where I'm going with
this but I I'm not as upset about the
I'm not like the phrase loot crate or
like a loot box doesn't automatically
bother me because like Peter said like
you're hoping there's plenty of games
where you're hoping for a good drop or
you're hoping to get something and it's
giving you a goal to work towards I it's
kind of what a lot of games do yeah cuz
they have alpha packs in Rainbow six now
so every time you win a match you have
to specifically any time you finish a
match multiplayer or terrorist hunt or
whatever you get an increase in
percentage which can go higher if you
have a season pass but you get an
increase in the chance to win a pack at
the end of a win you can only get packs
on a win so you win them and then you
open in it's like a rarity maybe it'll
be a weapon skin may be able to be a
headgear for castle or for tachanka
those are operators not just random
words the chung-kai he's like known as
the the worst operator the game he's got
this big turret people call him Lord to
chunka he I don't I don't like him he so
but the Alpha packs actually you don't
know what you're getting in those and
you can buy those with real-world money
if you buy worried about six credits
first and then spend those on alpha
packs which kind of sucks cuz I I know
those weren't always in the game but are
those things that like I think the
difference I think kind of what I'm
getting at is like the difference
between something like
at where you could spend money if you're
like trying to get a specific thing
you're looking for versus battlefront
where it seems like everything is
driving you to spend money because the
alternatives are so shitty
like with overwatch like I don't feel
like like I don't think spending money
on a loot crate is necessarily like the
game forcing you to spend money at
someone being like I really hope I get a
mercy skin yeah but like it doesn't give
you an advantage there's no there's no
reason to spend money on that lootcrate
other than I want to get this cool
cosmetic item because I love this
character or I'm playing this game a lot
I really really enjoy it yeah and like I
want something to work towards
because eventually like if you hit a
skill ceiling or you only play you know
kind of casually with a group of friends
and not everybody's at the same skill
level it's like where do you go from
there well you can get these kind of
like stretch goals basically for playing
the game but there's nothing about that
that screams like we're trying to get
you to spend money it's just kind of
like an option if you're really
passionate about it versus the
alternative is spending four thousand
hours playing a game of course I'm not
going to do that because I could work
for four thousand hours driving lift and
make money and like [ __ ] it right like
any time when you have to wrestle with
the idea where you think about it oh
great you know I mean we're like an
example like us I mean so you're saying
for Rainbow six like to get those
operators you can get them quicker right
bye bye ping that that's what you were
saying yeah if you have the season pass
okay and well and I'm like any operator
say you were to get in the game that you
don't have any unlock you were just be
using the recruit until you unlock
certain specific ones for at a concern
for defend you would either be able to
spend those Rainbow six credits or the
renown what you earn in-game and it
takes a while with a renowned in-game
for not for the base 16 operators or
however many there are but with year one
and year two operators those all are
like 25,000 renowned each now which is a
lot that's what that'll take you like I
think I played a full day Sunday and I
might have gotten like 6500 renown and
then hey I am infinity is telling me you
can't spend actual money on the Alpha
packs you can only spend renown on the
Alpha Pack
so then anytime you want to actually buy
something randomized that's with in-game
currency so you can't spend real money
on something randomized packs yeah so
that's not gonna be for gambling yes
situation presumably right Fran so
that's what another reason thank you hi
hey I'm infinity that makes the game not
as predatory I would say yeah and it
also it's ascetics and I still don't
love it because there are there is a
randomized element and I it does feel
like they make prolong the process to
try to get you to shortcut like a
free-to-play game might mmm-hmm
what about something like rocket League
which plays both sides of the discussion
right yeah because you can get gear by
playing and sometimes you'll get a but
you get a crate but of course you have
to spend money to open that crate so
it's kind of sucks because you do get
some stuff but then the game is
basically dangling like I'm not gonna
give you the free thing I'm gonna give
you the thing that's gonna cost you $1
to open it and then when you open it you
get something random and that kind of
sucks it does but the thing is is that
the you can't do it in the game directly
necessarily but there are plenty of
websites that even psionics points to
for trading items with players right
whether you actually have the option to
to give up something you don't want to
somebody else for something you do want
and people and chat are sure to let you
know that having the trade option is so
helpful yeah yeah
mining and rocket League at least does a
couple things I think that's that's I
guess you could say tasteful which is
like I think it's if you get there's two
things one is if you don't like that
system at all you can turn it off and
never see a crate yeah and never be
reminded and only just be getting as you
said like naturally these items or I
think this would be like maybe a tactic
with the game is you can turn it off and
then I believe check back on it maybe
like 10 hours later Stearman it creates
you can see any crates you got and then
flip five if you flip five of the same
crate you get a whatever higher tier
item out of it so you can you can do
that with the crates - okay great itself
no you can turn and create five crates
right the same type of I'm sorry what
yeah
yeah because I only knew that was a deal
with individual items that you've got
from crates I didn't realize you could
upgrade crates as well you might have
said this those have to be ranked
matches this all comes into play right
because I played casual I don't earn any
crates very slow man
yes I'm a casual that's and that's
that's a frustrating part is not knowing
when or how you get them like you want
to like you want to like link it to like
a good game or a good performance but
it's usually I put it like by chance two
hours into rocket League and I'll get at
least one crate yeah and that's always
my benchmark when I'm playing like it
homes like I'll play until I get a crate
it's usually it feels like within the
same amount of time sometimes I'll get
to like I'll get one right away and it's
like well that was only two minutes I'm
gonna keep playing yeah and that being
said though the the trading and the I
the the idea of trading back with items
is not a pretty system you it's not you
have told me that like you are unable to
do certain things like it's the upgrade
thing that you were talking about
trillion items so I have like the same
type of the same grade yes like oto take
five of these same type same item
category and you can exchange them well
I've got eight items that qualify but
then the game like lets me put those in
the bucket and then it goes oh one of
those items belongs to a series it
doesn't allow upgrades and it's like
then why did you let me put it in there
and which one is it I don't know you
don't I could improve right and actually
now I think but it to top that on is you
know when they first implement that that
system it was just there were just two
types of crates but now as a lot there
now so now you're diluting but the
chance of getting five of the said you
have said crate which is the rocket
League also does the other things that
we're discussing either you know I think
well right like you can pay money
outright for specific cars yeah okay
cars are cosmetics they don't make a
huge difference I think there's like my
new differences now the handle but
ceramics also releases a lot of free
content and they have this game has been
out for over two years now and we are
continually getting like new modes of
play which Haraka League that can make a
big difference like that it was a drop
shot is that the name of the one yeah we
don't play that that often but that is
really fun like we do play that that's
really cool and some people that might
be their favorite mode in the game they
do keep adding a lot so I think rocket
League is a very interesting like thing
that has a slice of every tactic
that we're discussing which is and yeah
a strange and that's what I think we all
like to think now I think most people
like who are familiar with what used to
be the case with like things like
battlefield 4 right is when you're
locking these maps and you're paired
with a friend who has those maps and you
don't and you can't progress with them
into the next match like that's a
problem rocket League I mean titanfall 2
was an example of that like I was gonna
say titanfall 2 has done stuff pretty
well pretty really well yeah it's been a
little free map updates and modes and it
was monarch do you have to pay vermont
no no no using game stuff for monarch
the new titan that released three months
ago i think at this point but if you did
want to get new skins it's not crates
it's pay five dollars they litter it'll
be it won't be an in-game currency it'll
say pay $4.99 USD or whatever for this
Titan you know what you're getting the
entire time if you do want to splurge
and get a new skin for so your pilot or
your Titan will have a cool camouflage
whatever you know what you're getting
yeah it's all cosmetic and it is it's
very straight forward which is nice it's
just like here's you know here's a
bundle for like $20 and get all the cool
news like skins or a weapon it'll twist
every single thing that you're getting
it yeah exactly and if you don't want
the bundle do you know what I just you
know I use one that's why I do a couple
times actually many times because I love
this game so like I will happily
purchase these cosmic X's as we said
earlier like I love this game I still
love this game it's just I feel like I'm
helping that studio two-degree like
we're great passion for the game rather
than like feeling like ah the exchange
rate for time to money is too steep I
thought the game is holding anything
back from yeah you're not paying money
to mate you're not paying real world
money to hopefully get that skin of that
Titan that you're shooting at because
you're on it you're paying money to
definitely have it the next match you go
in with scorch ready to scorch scorch
yeah and then it does remind me of again
Rainbow six none of the X there's no
gambling aspects the only time you open
something that you don't know it's gonna
be inside you can't spend real money
it's in-game stuff that your yeah that
it's just it's just winning matches that
you're gonna unlock that just by
happenstance or you can spend renown if
you have like three hundred thousand
saved up if you play that game regularly
and it games like titanfall to and
Rainbow six are rewarding players that
play regularly you know like so many
games are trying to do games of service
and I wish they would look at titles
like these more often cuz you look at
people everybody's mentioning Team
Fortress 2 was the first one to have
kind of spark blue crates and one I'd
had that random weekly item drop that
went up to a time Kevin everything yeah
and there was no guarantee you're always
could you would ever get anything you
wanted but then you look at something
like path of Exile if you guys played
this too much it's the dungeon crawler
kind of like Diablo s game but they've
been adding quests they've been adding
just in general new things to do
throughout its I forgot when it came out
now of like four years
yeah like almost four years ago now and
it's it's a good game it's more if
people who were kind of lamenting Diablo
3 as maybe too casual for people who
like Diablo 2 kind of path of Exile and
torchlight 2 but mainly path of Exile I
think was the more mainstream game that
kind of captured a lot of the aspects
that they wanted in Diablo 3 and didn't
get maybe but it's they've been we just
had that they have a new update they
just announced recently and there's just
whole new areas kind of like Diablo 3
did but um I was talking to Eric Tate
other day and he was watching I think a
streamer doing Diablo 3 but they do
kanai's cube and everything was probably
the last big update but most of them
just been smaller new areas and
challenges for adventure mode if you
want to do that or just kind of quality
of life things but path of Exile is also
great if you play that you probably know
that they've been supporting this game
really well since lost this listened to
launch this looks great yeah it's really
good it's it's it's a huge game if you
want to get into it now it's like yeah
it's a it's fantastic it's good I when I
was on editorial I used to do the
preview stuff for the updates we know an
editorial no more boy I know what about
GTA 5 this one's kind of a weird one
yeah yeah yeah
hundred bucks on this new vehicle played
a lot of that online but definitely
dropped off and it's not necessarily an
example of a great post release system
but it's interesting because I think
some things are pretty neat like
highlights of like how they have done
stuff I think is just a super strong
community that they've like listened to
and and have taken advantage of as far
as like hey like this weekend it's like
double xp you know like consistently
like rewarding people who really do like
that online who keep returning returning
but and I I'm pretty sure this is the
case is that would like when you start
hearing with like some of the last
updates they've had is like just the
cost of some of these cars and so my god
and then yeah that's part of it too is
the cost of like there's one there's one
update where they added like that rocket
glider motorcycle
yeah there's you know explosive sniper
rifle rounds dope and who's this but
these these are expensive because this
is you know the the dollar currency and
you can get that char card and get those
things quicker but you know they're
they're two three million in game at the
conversion I can't remember yeah how
long would like three million in-game
dollars take you to get oh really I mean
when I was playing it it was tough it
was a really it was it would take you a
while you'd have to like play only you
know there's the grinding method stuff
like well this this mission like rewards
you with like you know the most money so
you just remember like playing this and
just consistently playing that said
mission over and over again because
there's a highest reward but you're
still putting a lot of time and there
are no gambling aspects right you know
what you're getting when you pay money
real money and GTA ores are you saying
the opposite I don't know it's and you
you just you literally buy the like the
dirt bike with jets on it you don't buy
the actual item per se you just get you
you put money into the currency so like
yeah you and then spending real-world
money in two dollars is was a more
discerning game money or your
yeah okay but yeah I mean people work I
saw complaints about this was like this
really cool old 1980s Mustang looking
thing is like more expensive than the
first update of like a really awesome
the one of the first like high-end cars
like if you compare the two like how can
I mean inflation is I guess what it is
over time right like they just they push
those vehicles and those items like
farther in part of the way I think but
yeah I mean I don't know I think there
are things to look at GT online that are
pretty great Kelly like the community I
think is really strong Kelly you're
mentioning Pokemon also does like
regular free gifts semi-regular yeah I
wanted to bring us something like an in
a little bit of a different vein from
like shooters and and stuff like that
just because like there isn't content
you can pay for necessarily outside of
just the game that you get but they give
regular free gifts of items and rare
Pokemon and so one of the good things
for this is like for competitive players
like that's that's the community that
needs to continue to have activity like
obviously you can play Pokemon by
yourself but for the competitive
community to thrive people need to
continue to play and there's a circuit
all year where people enter and stuff
like that and so last year or I guess it
was this year they gave out a shiny top
of cocoa which has a legendary Pokemon
that I caught and I didn't there's like
things you can do like soft resetting to
get the best version of that Pokemon
possible and it's a really popular
Pokemon in the competitive scene and I
had a really garbage one and they gave
out a like a competitively viable like
super perfect version for people and it
was almost like here like we know that
not a lot of you were caught up like
here's a way to catch up and kind of
like get back into this and it was nice
we were tangent for me when I see that I
was feeling like doesn't have to value
the game like the point of playing it to
try to get these things and devalue
maybe the edge of competition that one
player has over another so I would I
would say that if it they were giving
out like perfect stat Pokemon that you
could breed yourself but there's only
one opportunity in the whole game to
catch top of cocoa and there's only one
so
if you catch it you have to restart the
entire game to get a better one right or
you have to soft reset for hours and
hours to get the one that you want while
you're at that battle so for like in my
case
sounds good convenience it's doing fries
it's a convenience thing right but then
isn't everyone is rolling to battle with
that same free type of cocoa no no
because this is like kind of it's like a
standard build and it's it's hard to
really explain without getting to in the
weeds but basically there's six stats
and you're only guaranteed to have three
perfect stats for a gift Pokemon like
that for a gift legendary Pokemon and so
screw you still restart the game if you
want to be a competitor yes so so you
get that gift and you can still like I
know people who when that gift was in
circulation did a bunch of soft
resetting to get the best one possible
and even then people were like this
isn't this is like the closest to
perfect I'll get so I there's still an
element of like if you want to get a
super super perfect one you still have
to put in that work but it's it's a way
to to get people caught up and it was
right at the end of the competitive
circuit for the year so I just I don't
know I brought up Pokemon because it's a
little bit of a different case of like
you can't pay money for a Pokemon like
that there's no way to be like oh I'll
pay $5 and all of my Pokemon eggs will
hatch faster and then all you know
breeding will be faster or whatever but
I do think that they do a good job of
continuing to support players by being
like hey it you might not have this item
or you might not have this rare Pokemon
here's this free gift for this period of
time and it still like because it's such
a there's a luck element and you also
have to know how to use that Pokemon in
battle I don't think it gives you too
much of an edge like you can't like go
into battle at that Pokemon not knowing
what you're doing and win so I think
they do a good job of keeping that fair
yeah it's all in all I mean between
Rainbow six siege Witcher 3 titanfall 2
path of Exile I don't think we have time
but I want to talk more about warframe
apparently people are saying that game
is really really good now that they've
like been continually updating it
throughout when that released three
years in 13
damn that apparently like that games
fantastic now if I want to check it out
because people have been mentioning it
saying the team has been consistently
updating it if you want to it's like the
most popular game no one's talking about
yeah so hopefully I'll check that out
maybe over break I need something to
dive into but Rainbow six siege is also
been taking my attention but anyway and
then I poked him on GTA 5 online with
more games trying to do the games of
service thing you hope that they're
gonna look to the good examples in the
future rather than continue stuff that
will piss people off you know as an
interesting example I just thought of
was actually Wolfenstein - what are
those those things that keep rolling out
there are like the like short stories
yeah they're like yeah it's not really
deal see you don't pay for it though
they just like roll those out for free
yeah I think it's interesting because
it's basically the ones that there's
like three right now yeah they're there
one of each of the three gameplay styles
without spoiling it that you have access
to kind of halfway through the game so
it's kind of like it's nice because it
seems like they don't have to put too
much like mechanical effort into it it's
just an opportunity to explore a
different story and maybe a gameplay
style that you didn't like if you didn't
do stealth like oh you can do the
stealth girl's route I think it's
interesting it's kind of capitalizing on
hey maybe because you make this choice
halfway through the game you might not
if you're not the kind of person who
wants to replay but you want to
experience what like that one crazy like
stilts thing is yeah here's a thing and
it's like a pretty cool way of you know
I think so many single-player games have
that like quick drop-off right or once
you finish it you are gone but like
here's something that's like you're it's
almost like they're trying to fill in
the gap for whatever inevitable I would
imagine actual Wolfenstein 2 DLC there
will be yeah of course like just like
dropping off and like going silent and
like here's our deal see you like right
like you're cuz there's even like a
counter in the main menu where it's like
oh yeah I'll give it a shot I'll put in
like 30 minutes 20 minutes like every
couple weeks and the cool thing about
that is like they put so much effort
into building this world that it's
almost for me sometimes when I play a
single-player game like that I feel kind
of bad about leaving or I put off
finishing it because I'm like I'm not
ready to leave the world even though the
story is concluded and so with that it's
kind of like oh this is a chance to
maybe explore the world we've built for
you know in a more condensed you know
kind of like spin-off style yeah yeah
like I said hopefully other games will
look to these better examples as we go
forward
[Music]